It appears that there will be a fast way to obtain
your homologation of the title
in Spain,
February 21,
2024 the Ministry of
has published
a resolution where it mentions that certain persons
will be able to opt for a different life for
obtain homologation as soon as possible
and thus be working
in Spanish territory.
And who are these people?
are those legally residing in Spain,
who have nationality
Spanish or any other nationality
belonging to the European Union.
So far, the Ministry
has not said what this pathway is
and mentions that he will be publishing it
on its official website,
so we will have to be
very aware of this situation.
Let me know in the comments what you think
with respect to this new resolution